tout est une question d'entraînement
avec ce constat ne faut pas être un
coussin pour que vous nous faites peur
la patronne au nom son prénom sont
beaucoup moins connu que son physique
michel crémadès nous accueille dans sa
maison de bourgogne nous sommes à sens
pas très loin de paris un pas loin du
thé a pas loin du cinéma alors eh bien
c'est ce physique qui est le vôtre un
peu ingrat du loup le dire comment une
fois donnez moi vos mensurations aux
belges de mesurer à mettre 60 j aimais
ce sont trois à être un maître 61 je
gagne 2 cm et je dois faire dans les 52
kg ou un plus mounier mouloungui
guerrier les grands réalisateurs font
appel à vous comme costa gavras comme
molinaro comme idi fin j'en oublie
beaucoup
toujours dans les seconds rôles oui et
d'ailleurs le roi du second oui mais je
ne regrette pas du tout non parce que je
trouve que je me suis je n'ai pas
beaucoup pour défendre les seconds rôles
je trouve que c'est ce qui fait un petit
peu
tout l'est le fond de sauce d'un film ce
qu'on voit trop l'épreuve les premiers
rôles
les films sont trop bâti je trouve sur
des et tête d'affiche alors la voix
toujours en bas de la fiche par oh oui
mais je m'en fiche je m'en fiche parce
que
si on valoir tout à l'heure c'est un
second rôle qui vous a valu beaucoup
beaucoup de contrats et la renommée
c'est vrai que l'on vous connaît
aujourd'hui qui êtes-vous d'où venez
vous on va voir ça tout de suite petit
portrait depuis tout petit
vous est né à alger de parents
commerçants qui vous élève ou et vos
trois frères et soeurs dans une ambiance
toréador votre père se construit tout
seul son bateau est cool avec lui le
jour de sa mise à l'eau vos soeurs sont
folles de théâtre et pas vous pas encore
michel car à l'époque c'est plutôt la
chirurgie qui vous excite vous arrivé en
france à l'âge de 8 ans avec dans votre
valise le rêve de devenir un grand
footballeur ce n'est que beaucoup plus
tard que vous attraperez le virus du
théâtre par hasard dans un village de
vacances ou les gm nous appelle géo
encouragé par un public friand de votre
humour vous montez deux cafés théâtres
qui n'auront deux défauts que d'être en
province des scheiks salutaire qui vous
mène à paris prendre des cours d'art
dramatique
très vite tout s'enchaîne les ripoux
promotion canapé mito folie sous le
signe du poisson des séries comme maggie
la preuve par trois silence en coulisse
fantôme est votre cv est surbooké
télévision cinéma théâtre
[Musique]
on ne s'étonnera guère que vous ayez
épouse et bernadette la mère de vos
trois enfants en cinq minutes chrono et
que pour fêter l'évènement vous ayez
avalé un café serré et une boîte de
petit salé aux lentilles michel crémadès
comment avez vous fait pour bâcler
autant votre mariage volontaire oui
j'étais volontaire c'est vrai que ça
faisait
pas mal d'années que nous vivions
ensemble et puis on avait trois enfants
elle voulait pas se marier auriez pas
passer par quelqu'un dire on va se
marier vous êtes d'accord oui oui
échanger les bagues et puis un jour on
s'est dit quand même pour les enfants on
va faire ça regarde est allé avec un
témoin mon frère est le frère de
bernadette j'appartiens cinq minutes
vraiment pendant 5 minutes chrono pour
les enfants en fait ils étaient six à
provoquer avec sa mère ce que je sache
bon petit diable oui c'est vrai c'est
que ma fille aînée éoliens annoncés
comme le soin d'y voilà je viens je vais
te contentes papa maman s'est marié
aujourd'hui tu contente et elle a piqué
la nasa fait ouais j attends mais ça ne
fait pas plaisir dit non non parce que
toutes mes copines en classe qui ont
dans les parents étaient mariés et ont
divorcé alors vous avez raté votre coup
dit bon voilà la famille c'est important
même des trois enfants oui il est très
fort très très important d'internet la
cellule familiale ici à sens vous
rentrer chaque soir parce que c'est
votre résidence principale michel la
vocation médicale ça c'était sérieux
fonctionnerait à oui oh là là que petit
et d'appeler dès que j'avais un steak
dans l'assiette jeu le disséquer jouvray
regarder s'il y avait dedans je
m'achetais du mou pour le chat
j'ouvrais je m'étais toujours quelque
chose j'étais vraiment le chirurgien
j'étais dans mon personnage je dis c'est
que je refusais le coton j'avais tout ce
qu'il fallait pour ça qu'ils activent
actuellement je sais pas oui je mangeais
toujours froid que j'avais des revues
médicales de m'acheter ça à foison je
disais les opérations et j'ai même
assisté des opérations chirurgicales
plus tard j'ai vu huy des opérations sur
les yeux sur des enfants et c'est
passionnant c'est extraordinaire de voir
le sang froid quand ces types qui sont
sur les yeux d'une gamine qui explique à
d'autres voilà il faut recoudre comme ça
voyez pas trop les profondes
je suis émerveillé parle pas ça pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas fait médecine pourrait
récupérer métier parce que d'un côté on
dit que c'était très très long il
fallait quelques années
c'est moi landais déjà cette année et
dix ans dix ans otto entre-temps bon je
voulais faire médecine c'est vrai entre
temps j'ai rencontré le foot alors ça ça
m'a un peu dévié et après je rencontrais
la scène alors ça ça fini par vraiment
me dévié alors le foot le foot le foot
chaudière fou de foot foot passion
passion ah oui c'est vrai que depuis
tout petits ruminants il faut dire aussi
que mon père jouait au foot ils jouent
au foot il des gardiens de but et puis
j'ai eu beaucoup de photos de lui et ça
c'est que vous et je continue à bien
jouer au foot à sens alors dans un
endroit un petit peu particulier oui
c'est oui on dirait des chefs pourquoi
va-t-il jouer au foot la semu
l'important c'est à l'école de police de
chance on se fait des petits mal de
temps encore on se régale avoir acquis
une panne de deux de couple formidable
parce que je vois souvent le plus
souvent possible quand je peux quand je
tourne pas quand je joue pas au théâtre
oui à quel point we all alors on le
dirait platini l'a tellement on se
toucher de ballon ça me rappelle platini
alors où vous jouez sur leurs terres je
joue plutôt demi milieu de terrain c'est
à dire que je sais distribuer les
ballons temps en temps j'essaie de
marquer on courait beaucoup râlent je
cours beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup et peu une manière de me
détendre qui fait beaucoup de bien aux
le penalty signe de croix cette plénière
centration ça
m eh bien eh oui ça c'est la frime ça
c'est évidemment de ces latrines savent
avec vos joueurs
racontez-moi bon souvenir de foot ça
s'est passé il ya plusieurs années j'ai
joué en lever de rideau de bordeaux
marseille et on était toute une équipe
c'est la première fois qu'on joue
ensemble il y avait il y avait encore
nina y avait le groupe gold il y avait
patrick bruel il ya cabrel qui a joué 5
minutes et qui a sorti d'une mission
pouvait plus la jouer contre des avocats
mars et et c'est un souvenir pour moi
jouer à bordeaux prendre ce long couloir
descendre le bruit des crampons j'avais
des poils dressés comme ça tellement
l'émotion quand on dans le stade où il
ya tous les supporters
c'est génial
et puis jouer sur ce terrain qui est
immense et perdre 6 0 c'est génial elf
écrasée de laminer par les avocats mars
et où il veut il jouer il faisait la
coupe du monde des avocats nous a
parfois qu'on joue ensemble alors on a
au début le prurit en ont été menées à 0
et puis deuxième mi temps se sont
réveillés il faut dire que avons en
effet un excellent déjeuner on les avait
fait boire ils ont mis toute une mettant
une mi-temps pour de l'intérieur de
mettre un petit peu
mais garder le maillot c'est venir
j'avais gardé le maillot rigide est dans
l'oeil oui j'ai même gardé les
chaussettes j'ai toujours sur moi
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours mes chaussettes
qui m'ont servi dédicacé il ya cabrel a
souligné tout le monde a dédicacé j'ai
tout ce qu'il faut j'ai même gardé les
chaussures qui vont servir à l'époque
j'ai toujours mais à l'époque j'étais
plus petit donc je sens que j'ai encore
pu peut-être crétins et ce sont des
belles chaussures mais je n'avais pas
marqué aucun but de ce journal
alors nous sommes à 100 ce sampling
bourgogne pourquoi ils devaient quitter
paris est ce que vous arrêtez de
travailler est ce que vous préférez vous
reposer ou bien pourquoi ce choix
d'abord j'ai un petit ras-le-bol de de
paris et puis je trouvais que j'ai
donnent priorité mais la qualité de vie
pour moi et mes enfants et ma femme
parce que je trouve que c'est important
pour et c'est vrai que ici j'ai trouvé
mon bonheur pour l'asie alors quand je
joue au théâtre quand je tourne sur
paris j'ai parfois des périodes où je ne
travaille pas
donc si c'est pour rester là-bas et
entend des klaxons et gens stressés là
je préfère être là être bien dans mon
jardin et récupère et regards et oui ça
c'est en gardant la main verte en plus
pas que la main
on
parce que ces ions ce métier
c'est plus
[Musique]
alors ça c'est votre jardin vous allez
nous commenter les images parce que vous
avez beaucoup pioche et biner faire
pousser les fleurs les légumes oui oui
c'est vrai quand on a eu la chance de
trouver cette maison en pleine ville
avec un magnifique jardin à l'ancien
propriétaire nous a laissé un lieu
formidable et je continue j'entretiens
mais pommiers et les poiriers
mais mes fleurs et des confitures je
fais mes confitures oui j'ai fait y'a
pas longtemps j'ai pu refaire une combe
des confiture de framboises ça repousse
et avec le beau temps qui l'a fait jean
venait pas du revenu un jour de relâche
et puis j'ai ramassé tout ça j'ai fait
mais confiante et vous faites aussi de
la cuisine on vous a récompensé
d'ailleurs appris oui je t'aime pris un
peu un peu spéciales postées c'était un
concours il y avait quelques comédiens
comédiennes tu faisais des plats salés
et sucrés j'ai pris un plat sucré il y
avait tous les plus grands chefs de
france qui goûtaient ses plats est
arrivé j'ai un oui fait pourquoi c'est
qu'est ce que c'est c'est pour le foot
revient maintenant je ne peux pas je
suis un jeu peut surgir une interview tu
viens de changer tout à l'heure pour
vous mais attendez pour la 3e mi-temps -
mettez la gomme c'est le foot voilà
c'est passé deux mois sous le sable si
je suis un peu le buteur dans la poêle a
toujours la position après moi j'attends
que je suis près l'âge est prêt à bondir
et j'ai tout ce qu'on vous ou presque
prêt manquent les os et donc j'ai servi
âge aurait servi à ces grands chefs
français et un souffle et à la banane
ils en sont jamais remis il était mort
de rire parce que le soufflé à la banane
son président c'est jaune là c'était un
petit peu verdâtre
alors je l'aurais du genre est déjà
l'objet de topmada
ils ont tellement ri qui n'auraient pas
goûté de souffler ils ont ils me
décerner un prix qui n'existait pas le
prix de l'humour on a beaucoup ri et
manger et j'ai goûté il n'est pas
mauvais mais
eux qui ont quand même le palais plus
fins m'ont dit c'est pas mauvais mais
votre spécialité à vous quand vous
faites pas du délire comme ça c'est gros
j'aime bien j'ai aimé travailler au
barbecue est prêt à faire les petites
choses comme ça
sinon que ce que j'aime bien travailler
aussi les légumes ah oui c'est un peu
pour ça que j'aime bien avoir des
légumes tomates le jardin des fruits
cuisinier fins gourmets figé oui je juge
apprécie plus de
de goûter de taper un bon repas plutôt
que de cuisine svq cuisiner c'est
souvent pour moi c'est plus le plaisir
de recevoir des gens et déjà faire
quelque chose et pour moi me faire
manger pas très je me faisais faux-plat
terminée rions un peu parce que vos
débuts c'était le petit théâtre de
bouvard il ya longtemps et la mairesse
14 c'était environ 80 un jeu croisé des
81 et avec toute une bande de copains
alors inconnu la première équipe de
l'aude tout provient oui gt gt même le
premier à passer avec mon partenaire
l'audition devant philippe bouvard qui
ont été les premiers puisque mon
partenaire à l'époque s'appelait aquilon
à aïda il avait fait une liste
alphabétique il a dit moment j'ai appelé
rémois kg et son partenaire michel
crémadès voilà l'intitulé du skate c'est
ça à les y improviser fait moins rire
et on était complètement d'accord et
tous les copains ont fait est ce que
vous restez les premiers à passer on a
passé notre sketch
c'est très drôle vous restez là je fais
passer vos camarades et le têtes de
bovins et était parti cette fois le
premier sketch l'a convaincu le risque
est le thème qui nous adresser un
employé vient demander une augmentation
oui c'est un emploi il vient demander
une augmentation à son patron et
les rémois qui l'emmenait était de
dt antilles est de couleur noire et j'ai
dit à philippe bouvard j il vaut mieux
qu'ils fassent un point je vais faire le
patron il s'en amuse beaucoup et déjà ça
des vins et bien et donc on a improvisé
complètement notre truc cela fait
beaucoup rire et puis de là c'est parti
c'est parce que toute la fine équipe
alors un petit exemple souvenirs
chirurgie esthétique avec smile gakpé
olala que souvenirs
[Musique]
garantis pas encore cei
c'est quoi ça
buisson oui ça va ça va
bougez pas
comme ça
allez voir dans la grâce des valeurs si
tu peux
c'est pas la peine huit mois comme ça
sans administration vous êtes venus
comment il est
beau souvenir non plus vous voyez
toujours sept copains oui ah oui c'était
un très très bon et je garde cette
expérience de théâtre de bouvard un
souvenir ému et c'est vraiment c'est
celle où vraiment j'ai tout tous mes
copains de desbuquois qui ensuite chacun
fait sa carrière dans le temps et dans
son sang par le temps a passé qui vous
fait rire vous fait rire mais chaloupe
qui vous fait rire
c'est difficile pour ferrari est assez
difficile parce que je passe que
j'essaie en même temps que je regarde
quelque chose et c'est d'ailleurs un
tort j'analyse pourquoi ça fonctionne
pourquoi ça fonctionne pas mais je te
dire que y'en a qui vraiment me fait pas
toujours bon fait beaucoup rire je
regarde régulièrement à chaque fois dès
que je me colle devant le devant la
télévision et je regardais une cassette
et c'est louis de funès j'avoue que il
avait là un comique qui me laisse très
sensible c'est d'une précision et je
regarde souvent ces films image par
image howie de scop et je vois la
manière dont ils regardent la précision
la rigueur et ça je trouve ça très fort
en dehors de l'ubs rien il ya au bout
dit allen que j'aime particulièrement un
des plus grands pour moi c'est quand
même charlie chaplin j'essaie
inspiré par an mais non c'est vrai que
tu ris chaplin c'est pour moi un des
maîtres arriver à faire passer autant de
choses sans rien dire je crois que c'est
un travail important pour moi que
j'essaye de faire un travail corporel
avant de parler justement ce travail
vous le faites en observant beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup le quotidien et c'est
ce qui vous a valu et bien ce petit
morceau dont les ripoux je voudrais que
vous me racontiez avant comment vous
avez analysé une scène de la vie
quotidienne que vous avez vécu dans le
métro je crois oui qui vous a servi on
réduit tout à fait donc on va faire le
parallèle racontez-nous d'abord les
prémices oui c'est vrai que je devais
tourner ce film je savais ce que je
devais faire dans ce film de claude zidi
et donc
j'ai pris métro une fois j'ai descendu
sur le quillier j'ai vu un type qui
avait une respiration un peu bizarre
c'est pas hésité pas à une manière de se
comporter comme on se comporte sur un
quai de métro c'est à dire ajouter sur
dans une cigarette à mâcher du
chewing-gum à regarder si le métro
arrive il était un petit peu tendue à
l'intérieur et je me suis pas se jeter
sur le rail non non non et puis j'ai vu
derrière lui à une quinzaine de mètres
un autre type qui était pareil qui
transpire et la même façon qu'il est une
respiration un peu bizarre je me suis
dit ils sont ensemble ces deux là et
puis la ram est arrivé j'ai senti lésé
de plus en plus tendus les portes se
sont ouvertes il regardait comme ça les
gens sortir donc il ne mentait pas dans
le métro ce qui allait dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'attendait pas le
métro où il attendait autre chose et il
ya deux dames qui sont descendus éclore
sadaoui c'était une entrée de papoter et
puis naquit à vue qui a fait signer
ils ont suisses
et leurs sacs et ils sont partis comme
ça j'avais dit ça je le suis c'est
magnifique garde sa enregistre ça dans
ta ka set c'est ça qui vous faire dans
le film et moi je suis monté dans le
train les portes sont fermées je suis
parti et une station plus tard le 6 mai
j'ai réalisé de bonnes femmes et ensuite
piqué les sacs et c'était trop de
professionnels alors ses pulsions elle
voulait tester parfois vous êtes un peu
dur choix sur votre famille c'est à dire
que vous êtes capable de tomber dans les
pommes ou pourvoir pour vendre est en
provence et la réaction 26 grossesse
j'ai bien joué
pour témoigner de vos pulsions la
dernière qu'est ce que vous avez
et vous amuser comme ça oui j'étais
c'est à dire que je
j'ai par exemple je le téléphone
quelqu'un rentre dans ma femme j'ai le
téléphone et je mets mais c'est pas
possible enfin te retrouves pas qu'on
vive enfin c'est pas vrai non et alors
là je la sens qui se tend de plus en
plus et je la regarde je me dis réagi
comme ça par rapport à cette situation
et gardent bien sain et pendant qu'on va
te faire [ __ ] je raccroche et puis je
pars en improvisation si c'était qui
c'est pourquoi j'y vais ça
on fait la
meilleure entente est nu arrive et que
c'est miss et oui mais vous c'est un peu
c'est un peu là là là bas je crois qu'un
du théâtre c'est de regarder dans la vie
de tous les jours ce qui se passe et de
pouvoir le reproduire c'est sympa de la
deuxième étape le plus difficile alors
vous êtes malade mais vous vous soignez
c'est à dire que enfin vos amis je peux
malabo attendez
vous loges sont transformés en
véritables boutiques avec des petites
qu'elles partout parce que vous avalez
les tapis ou alors on bute a surpris à
100 cela eh ouais vous êtes allez vous
approvisionner oui c'est vrai regardez
on a la preuve alors qu'elle est venue
chercher dans ses boutiques et des
cessions des produits et va la nature
yaser de ce sont des produits nature
naturel qui est vraiment me vaut
beaucoup de bien jours c'est vrai quoi
vous prenez quoi des poudres de
perlimpinpin
je rentre fatigué et puis je dors dans
le magasin et
puis je ressors généralement en pleine
forme mais bon j'ai fait quelques
quelques achats entre temps
25 kg de marchandises non c'est surtout
jeu je marche beaucoup jean 5 à la gelée
royale ça c'est formidable à la gelée
royale est
je marche avec de la serre au lac et de
la vitamine c naturelle et puis j'ai
j'achète beaucoup de deux produits de
fruits des légumes en plus c'est bien ça
tombe bien puisque c'est ma frangine qui
tient le magasin
des bons produits elle me dit ça prend
ça c'est nouveau ça c'est bien au delà
et c'est vrai que ça vous fait du bien
c'est nécessaire pour votre équilibre
oui ce sont des produits naturels et
c'est vrai que
je siège à jour ôta tristan bernard une
pièce et j'avais réservé une loge qui
était la loge le casse croûte avec tous
ses produits avec en plus des bananes
des fruits secs des abricots raisins et
les copains soudés de magasins et
expliques tu prends ça et au bout de
trois jours ils venaient une pique et
toutes les marchandises et il rigolait
bien parce qu'il y avait un produit
qu'il faisait beaucoup rire qui
s'appelle le popb la poudre duit
portugaise sauvages ils sont ce soir en
dragées que vous faites pousser dans
votre jardin c'est ce qu'on va voir tout
de suite comme tout le monde je les
achète plutôt subtile vous ça va plus
vite
en plus vous leur parlez
thibaut
petit bout tu veut m'aider
oui tu va couper les tomates
allez
[Musique]
ramassez tomates mais que l'on ramasse
alexis est celle là
allez tiens c'est moi ça vous avez lui
ce faire une salade de tomates soir dans
l'air ça c'est vrai ça c est bonne c'est
l'agent du bourg au totem pas mais non
même et je vais jouer le rambo de la
fleur rien
michel bouquet un
gars me
tiens
camille
qu'est ce qu'elle fut et assure
n'aurait-il boire est
quoi bein oui s'applique mais s'est posé
il faut mettre des gants pas parce
qu'elle me dit que tout
allait bien j'ai payé un peu vient voir
ici
et puis vous êtes un homme de nature
naturel et nature à wissant et le voit
tout le temps c'est me croirez vous
aimez beaucoup vous promener ici à san
suu kyi au départ qui a beaucoup de
choses revisité avec vous
allez
c'est parti pour une visite à tanger
dans des endroits et forcément en
relation avec votre métier oui comme ici
c'est un lieu magique c'est le théâtre
municipal de chancy un petit y est
magnifique à l'italienne je crois qu'il
ya 400 places et c'est très beau il ya
des parterres de fleurs autour du
théâtre c'est c'est eh ben voilà on le
voit bien ce petit air il est il est
minuscule mais les tout-petits petit
brevets et puis alors il ya la
cathédrale et pas mal de menus et puis
des parcs ah ben ça c'est la ballastière
le parc lebas la cia c'est bien parce
qu'on peut y aller en vélo avec eux en
famille en fait la fête on va soit la
ballastière wyss évoqué avec le avec lui
à bavois la casquette de la ji et
auxerre
elle est folle envie sur le
sel petite fille ouais c'est camilla
dernière et d'étoilés la zone thibaud
julie est la maman qui suit
vous venez vous aérer comme ça le
week-end n'en
reste pas là des succès c'est magnifique
on va là on va au moulin au parc non au
moulin s'agit bien au moule est atteint
c'est très très très beau combat aussi
montré la même année tendance air et
puis là on est à cinq minutes de la
maison de ceux de ce grand parc de la
ballastière petits bourges plus combien
d'hectares
vous pêchez 15 ha oui j'adore la pêche
mais je préfère la pêche en mer
je me connais souvient pêche au gros et
j'aurais du mal parce que je sais pas si
je pourrai sortir un gros j'ai pas de
ces gros pour ça et voilà bois nous a
gênés de ballon des parties d'un dans
l'eau et vous allez dire vrai je vais le
chercher voilà c'est le vannes oc un peu
la revue jane's
j'ai sauvé la situation alors on sait
que vous vous rêviez de fer chirurgien
puisque 10 et qu'elle le bifteck le mou
du chat vous avez fait comédien et puis
j'aimerais savoir si vous croyez
ultérieurement quoi elle me riez vous
être réincarné ou exercer un autre
métier ou quelle serait votre rêve j'ai
toujours dit que si oui je crois que si
je veux si je venais
dans une autre vie j'aimerais revenir
peut-être dans la médecine je dirais
vont dire oui également au théâtre si je
devais revenir
1,6 g sous la forme d'un animal j'ai
toujours dit que j'aime tellement les
roses que j'aimerais revenir sous la
forme d'abus seront pas ce que je sais
c'est après les roses accroché c'est
vrai que c'est tellement magnifique je
trouve ça mal
partout c'est vrai que c'est une forme
une odeur un parfum
j'aime les fleurs en général puisque
j'ai une très belle fleur à la maison
qui est ma femme
et puis alors vous leur offrez une
spectacle rose vous les aimez tellement
qu'à vous n'hésitez pas à danser pour
elle tout ce que vous avez fait vous
aimez danser nue oui
c'est au tout tout tout l'europe même le
rock acrobatique oui j'ai même des
villes et une fois en essayant
d'apporter s'est retrouvé comme un
aspirateur qui concerne la peau mais on
va d'abord j'ai appris à danser beaucoup
le slow avec elle et puis j'ai posé mes
trois enfants et après on
va être légaux
j'adore le tango c'est un peu la routine
ces personnes je joue d'ailleurs la
puissance mouvement rôle de l'argentin
donc c'est un peu ça me fait ça fait
dans votre élément là et vous l'avez
connu e balade on ne vend pas j'ai dit
non non non non non j'en boîte contenant
mais c'est vrai que
très vite et puis industries dont c'est
entendu c'est vrai que c'est important
on s'est mis à danser et ensuite 28
scolaire n'a pas eu besoin de travailler
pendant deux heures pour très vite
ensuite
trouvé voilà très vite on s'est trouvé
ça n'est pas de la danse alors en finit
en tango argentin au milieu des fleurs
dans le jardin de sens où vous habitez
c'est votre résidence principale merci
michel canada tout savoir au sujet merci
à vous merci
[Musique]